vallée du panjshir première ligne de
front dans ces montagnes se joue la
bataille pour l'afghanistan
c'est ici que se sont retranchés les
hommes du commandant massoud pour
combattre avec l'aide du relief les fous
d'allah l'ennemi taliban
nous sommes au poste le plus avancé
quelques mètres de plus et là bas dans
le virage ce sont les talibans la fin de
l'hiver a sonné la sortie des tranchées
ce ne sont pas encore les grandes
offensives de printemps mais depuis que
la neige carbonique mais
rené sont rythmées par de petits
accrochages
nora mode est un outil dit un combattant
son père était moudjahidine il est tombé
sous les balles de l'occupant soviétique
à l'époque où rahman était trop jeune
pour se battre mais aujourd'hui il est
fier de lutter en première ligne a tué
des talibans
oui depuis combien de temps combattu set
en sept ans notre traducteur a du mal à
le croire mais qu'importe son commandant
en première ligne est fier de lui de
combat quel sentiment cela vous
procure-t-il de voir arriver de si
jeunes moujahidines très bien ils sont
la relève
ses attaques répétées au mortier vont
provoquer la réplique de la deuxième
ligne
les accrochages dans la vallée talibans
ce sont des bêtes sauvages la plupart ne
sont heureusement ils ont été stoppés
dans cette vallée du panjshir avec les
deux numéros pour l'heure la seule
lettre qu'elle l'assemblée leur apporter
c'est l'instant de la prière un répit
assuré pendant lequel les tirs s'arrête
et c'est bien là l'ironie de cette
guerre des deux côtés du front c'est le
prophète qu'ils invoquent des deux côtés
du front ces temps sont lentes ou le
combattent